they want to create the intensity that
comes with swearing and so you have this
sort of interesting way of overcoming it
yeah I think I think when Rob knew we
were gonna be streaming he he was all
excited because he finally could get the
vision of Veronica Mars that he's always
wanted and there were gonna be a lot of
swear words a lot of a lot of like think
there were like 14 or 18 and the first
word was you pull up on Veronica in her
car and she can't get through the gate
the first word of dialogue was Veronica
going and in that tone of all that
sexual stuff and the swearing your wife
showed Abby that way but Hulu apparently
said no we wanted the pg-13 and I think
that was the biggest Rob said
substituted yeah so there's a gag that
Keith and Veronica have they make a bet
who's the first person to swear so
instead of it's cus you see you guys say
it's a little yes like this custom that
get out of my cussing way because it's
like the good place a little bit like I
mean yeah
[Applause]